so who would have thought that an
independent romance movie would have
inspired one of the best trilogies of
our time definitely not this guy
the Ford midnight is directed by Richard
Linklater and it stars Ethan Hawke and
Julie Delpy this film is actually the
third film in a trilogy the first film
was called before sunrise and it was
about a couple that simply met on a
train on their way to Paris and the
entire film is just that one day then
walking through Paris just talking and
learning about each other that's the
whole movie and it is so beautiful it's
one of my favorite romance films it's
sequel before sunset was made nine years
later in 2004 the first one came out of
95 that film was then by chance running
into each other again and simply
spending the entire day talking to each
other except they were older and more
mature now and they had different
outlooks on life those two films were so
so beautiful and made me want to
immediately go to Paris essentially what
the movies were really about were just
showing the way people interact talking
about life goals and things that they
thought of and their thoughts on
politics and love and all kinds of
things and you just got to watch these
two people talk like a fly on the wall
so I was very excited for before
midnight which finally came to Cleveland
last weekend I got a chance to see it
this film is excellent it's an even more
mature version than the last one because
the characters are now 9 years older
than they were before and it's something
so interesting that he's taking each 9
years to make another movie and he's
presenting the same characters in the
same type of a really long takes almost
like a theatrical play and you get to
watch these people talk and go back and
forth and talk about how they feel and
as you watch all three films the first
ones about young love and how you are
when you're young and you meet someone
the second one was more mature and it
was about how people view love when they
get a little bit older and the third
one's more about how people view
marriage life love and even death and
their thoughts on that and it's so
beautiful to watch how these characters
have matured to this point and honestly
this movie is really just a series of
very long takes and discussions in which
you watch two people live over the
course of the day this one takes place
in Greece while they're on vacation and
their discussions are so riveting and so
well acted Ethan Hawke and Julie Delpy
both are oscar-worthy in this movie and
they also contributed to the screenplay
just like they did with before sunset
which was nominated for Best Screenplay
and I real
really think this one should be to this
movie and all of them really are some of
the most interesting thought-provoking
looks on romance that I've ever seen on
film and it was truly refreshing to see
this movie in theaters amongst the big
summer action blockbusters which are fun
in their own right but it was just so
nice to take a breather and just watch
two people talk and have these masterful
actors really work that dialogue it all
just feels just in the moment like
you're watching it really happening this
one has a different quality to it that
isn't as fun as the first two because
the first two still had that quality
where you're wondering are they going to
get together is the romance budding and
those first two had that suspense now
that they're already together on this
one it did lose that a little bit which
I thought made it not quite as good as
the first two nevertheless this is an
excellent movie I mean this is a really
good romance film and these three films
together are officially my favorite
romance films I strongly suggest
checking before midnight out I'm going
to give it a - thanks as always for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck
menage